hey guys and welcome back to lesson I'm
Cody my name is Ryan lesson so I have to
come clean and apologize that I had not
been getting my videos up as frequently
as I wanted to since my last video I've
actually moved from Dallas to Seattle so
if you're in the Seattle area be sure to
hit me up alright so the inspiration for
my next video comes from one of my
subscribers he countered on one of my
videos asking me to show him how to
build a to-do list with the angler 4
framework so you know I could have
showed him how to do that with England
for framework but you know what I
thought I'd make it even more
interesting so not only am I going to
build with the England for framework but
I'm gonna be using Redux as well to
manage the state of the application so I
thought any further ado let's hop into
the boilerplate code and the setup for
this application
so first up if you haven't already seen
my last video I built an angler web pack
starter kind of like a skeleton for your
project setup if you like to follow
along this whole project was built off
it so be sure to clone it down and I
include the link to the repo in the
description below okay so once you have
that clone down there's a couple things
you need to MPM install so things are
this Anglin redux store redux the reves
observable and T aside so I'll go into
it all these are doing a little bit
later and once you have all that we need
to also install JSON server which I'll
be using for my restful api and to do
that you will need to come to the
command line and run NPM install JSON
server - g4 global ok I'm not gonna run
this because again I already ABS
installed but if you do not have JSON
server installed please be sure to
install it globally alright and one last
thing is JSON server runs on by default
on port 3000 so we real quickly need to
go into a web pack dev config and change
it from port 4500 to port 3000 awesome
so that's all we need for this setup
let's hop right into building the
application
okay guys so first thing let's blew up
the application so let's come into our
command line and run npm run start
alright so while we wait for this to
compile and take a quick drink here Oh
God look compiling gives you time to
think and boom there we go okay so our
applications all booted up so as you can
see I gave you guys a quick UI
representation of how this to business
will be built the two's list will
consist of what to do with a name
property a description completed it
created I left some space here to add a
delete button alright so for each to do
we will be setting up grunt for it and
if you haven't heard of crud crud stands
for create read update delete so for
each to do we will be making you know
giving a crud you know functionality so
let's get started and with the first
letter is c4 create before we hop ahead
let's step on the brakes to talk about
the JSON server so the JSON server I'm
pretty sure you to pass in any JSON
object you specified and you basically
passed it in like this and it'll
basically set up a restful api which is
let's create read update delete
functionality for each object property
here so you can see for this to do is we
will have a restful api built for that
so it's very cool and very lightweight
to use a perfect for this demonstration
so after you guys see this we're gonna
go and delete this because again we will
be creating our to dues from our actual
UI over here okay so first things first
ice we're going to need to create a form
for us to actually create the to do so
let's go into our abdominal and let's
import the reactive forms module because
that's we're gonna be using to create
our forms and it's going to imports and
it's important awesome alright so next
thing we're gonna go into the app
component TS i'm gonna quickly scaffold
out the form here so I imported a couple
things that we're gonna need to set up
the reactive forms on model
and once you have all of that it's going
hero it screw the final on was called to
do form and it's going to be form group
okay and then let's inject in the form
builder the form builder is FB alright
and then right here let's do okay just
complain that I didn't create it yet
let's create right now and I don't like
that name and it to do for that's a lot
better okay so there we go have our
function so within this function within
this function we're going to return to
do form okay so now let's scaffold out
what its gonna look like okay so I'm not
gonna bore you with all this typing I'm
just gonna quickly go ahead and copy and
paste it over okay so here we go oh man
spelled it wrong already spell yours
okay so there we go we have the mild
setups and nos go ahead and create the
HTML for it and again I'm not gonna bore
you guys with me writing HTML I already
have it made so it's gonna quickly
uncommon it let's talk about it be sure
to set it up on the forum then give each
individual input you want to use form
control name and would be sure to give
the form anything with a foreign control
name a name property or it's gonna yell
at you and videos at you you're gonna
have a bad time
alright unless when I least had the
disabled to see until it's valid it's
not going to be on disabled and if you
remember who set required here so as you
could see the hot module replacement
already beat me to it
and here's our for
all right so we see if we come in we
basically type in there we go once it's
valid the add button will be there but
as you could might as you might as well
could guess the a button does not do
anything yet so now let's set up some
functionality for it to basically add a
you know what to do to this to news list
above and for that we'll be using redux
so let's dive in
okay guys
we start setting up read up this talk
about a quick history of it Redux was
built back in 2014 by the Facebook team
they're having problems managing complex
state of their applications so when I
say complex I mean Redux is actually
only supposed to be used for medium to
large scale applications of not for
to-do list but I will be billing in a
very scalable way so if you wanna you
know add to this it'll be very easy to
scale up front here um a couple things
about read up something I got my notes
right here I'm not a movie star just yet
Cameron brought my lights so read up
redox maintaining zap stay in a
predictable way and was built by
Facebook by blah blah it follows a flux
architecture but consists of couple
things it consists of a store which
contains the state of the app actions
that represent something that happened
and a reducer and the reducer is just a
function that specifies how a state will
change after an action happens so
basically we will be using a bunch of
actions and these actions will change
the state for us for our application so
Redux also uses pure functions for its
pure functions are functions that will
return the same thing that has the same
input in the same output so you will be
sure to have that and there's a couple
of reasons why I read US uses pure
function is because they're easily
testable easy to undo and redo because
of course we keep the previous state if
you know we're not mutating the previous
object and we could use time-travel
debugging which I will go into a lot
more in depth through this and you will
absolutely love it I guarantee it I love
it personally okay so let's go ahead and
start building out the architecture for
that so we're gonna come in here and
we're going to be creating our Redux
folder so let's go in here do new folder
and do Redux okay
so within our Redux folder we're gonna
have a couple things so we're gonna have
that actions folder I just talked about
we're also gonna have
[Music]
middleware which I'll get into later but
this is gonna be hard to be making HTTP
requests and reducers okay and we're
gonna put a new file in which is an it
state so for each redux file we're gonna
have to give it an its initial state for
the whole application and while it might
be hard to grasp from talking about once
I get the dev tools up and running and
show you exactly what it is it will all
make sense or hopefully it all makes
sense so I'm not going to bore you too
much with what I'm gonna be doing here
first I'm going to well bore you by me
having to type all this I'm gonna make
this fast I kind of copy and pasting so
we're gonna import combined reducers and
reducers again we're gonna build this
for scalability and we're gonna go ahead
and we're going to well that's all we're
gonna do there for now we're gonna go in
to reducers I'm gonna create a new file
and this file is gonna be called to do
reducer TS ah to do okay so we go in
there alright so there's a couple of
interfaces that I built that which I'm
not going to retype so here they are so
we're gonna have an an interface for it
to do which again will just be the name
description completed create and we
never I've used a which is gonna be the
array of the whole thing and it's gonna
have a couple more states of loading and
an error all right so I'll get to those
in more in depth in a second so let's
set up what the thing is gonna look like
so this is what our Redux objects gonna
look like this gonna manage all of our
state it's gonna have loading error and
it's gonna have an array of two dudes on
it okay so once we have that we're also
going to set up our route reducer or in
this case it's gonna be a to-do reducer
so this to do reducer well take in a
state of I to do state and that's going
to equal our initial state which we say
was to do state
and it's gonna has a passionate penny to
do state okay all right this is cannot
find to do reducer Oh cuz I didn't put
function it's silly me
okay so we're gonna go in there and so
basically we're gonna put a switch
statement in here so basically anything
that runs through this reduced function
is gonna look in this switch statement
for an action saying what's the fines I
shouldn't search for a turn state okay
okay so actions let's go talk about
actions so actions basically are gonna
be where they're gonna be called so
we're gonna be basically passing these
actions on this switch statement is
going to see the action so for instance
if the action was let's say update we're
gonna then return an update function
that we'll be creating and we're just
gonna basically come in here we're going
to define an update function so you can
see that top is gonna work it's gonna
basically you know run a switch
statement on the action that we pass up
and it's gonna run through this function
here and again there's going to be pure
functions so we're gonna be returning a
new object there okay not mutating the
original object alright so as you can
see from this example it's also you know
kind of hard to understand well it's not
hard to understand what I mean to say is
this update is very easily changed you
know this could be anything and we're
gonna run in problems at all that
actions on the switch you know we don't
want that we don't want users to error
that so we're gonna come into actions
they're going to create a few actions so
we're gonna come here we'll call it to
do actions TS okay so to do actions that
TS I'm just going to copy and paste
these we will
be okay and copy and paste this one over
as well okay so we will be having so
right here two things that we're going
to need is again we have to create read
update delete here's our read get to
dues and here's our create create to
dues you know just add delete and update
while we're at it okay
and where's cut words update that's what
Carl update complete why not okay so
there it is there's our create read
update actions and we're going to keep
these so the user can easily change them
in a constant that we're going to import
them into our reducer so let's go back
to our reducer let's go up here and
let's import them all in okay so there
we go got them all in oh it's to do
website - dues yeah oops okay so there
we go we have it in there okay so next
thing up is let's actually register this
with our app module so things need to do
is you need a register um your reducer
whether you have that module so let's go
ahead and do that okay
so I'm just gonna copy and paste over
these imports right here ah there we go
so that tools in section which is that
time traveling to bugger off talking
about earlier redux we dosed module
let's go ahead right in here I was
actually important to ng redox module
okay and then let's come here and then
let's import our initial state from that
file we just created there we go oh I
think I've read that with export on
those sorry about that guys yeah I'd
even Creedy I'm getting ahead of myself
okay so let's go
- are in it state and let's go ahead and
let's add a couple of interfaces again I
was going to copy and paste these I'll
just go over them real quickly for you
so first things first that's import what
we just created and our to do reducer
man that's so good there we go alright
and after we do that it's gonna copy and
paste some interfaces and we'll go over
all them alright so we're going to
import the active state that we created
to do reducer R to do initial state here
and the to do reducer itself here's the
initial State interface is going to be
what this is the root of our Redux
application this is going to be an
object that's gonna have it - duze
property on it the United State will be
to do is is to do state and to do state
if you remember it's just this right
here and then here we go we're gonna use
the combine to make it scalable um this
is actually very easy to add multiple
reducers to this okay so now that we
have all that let's go back to the app
that module and now let's register them
so I'm going to come into our app that
module and then we're gonna come down
here to our constructor and we're going
to inject a couple things into our
instructor excuse me constructor ng
redux
so we're gonna initialize ng read up
with the initial state object which we
previously defined we're going to inject
the dev tools an extension and we're
going and that's it for now actually
okay awesome
then after that we're going to quickly
set it up alright so this is how you do
it first of all let's talk if it's set
up that time traveling to bugger I'm
talking about earlier so here's just a
global variable that I defined the
webpack define that just tells us if
it's production or not in the production
environment so I was in the production
environment we don't want any enhancers
but if it's not in the production
environment we wanted to have dev tools
dots enhancers okay so this sense of the
time traveled to bugger this is actually
very important because if you have the
Redux dev tools debugger within your
application in production and this is
running like say Internet Explorer's
where I've seen this bug before the
whole application will crash so yeah
make sure that this is only turned on in
development mode okay so once you have
that there oh and the reason why that
happens is Internet Explorer I'm pretty
sure doesn't have the extension for the
Redux dev tools other than support it so
a good browser for this will be Google
Chrome and Firefox which I'll get to in
a second all right so once we have all
that and that's the not leases let's
configure the store all right so it's
going to take those reducers that we
combined it's going to take the initial
State it's gonna then take in middleware
here which we don't have any yet but we
will be adding and then the enhancers
okay and there we go now if I click here
you can see that we have read ups
installed and last but not least let's
talk about that I'm time traveling to
bugger um it's called
probably Redux dev tools extension I'm
pretty sure I'll leave a comment in the
description and what exactly this is I
want to pick it up this is in Google
Chrome and so you could come in here and
it's very cool
we can look me up an initial State
that's the initialize let's click on it
and see the state and you could see that
we have that to do the object we created
earlier and here it is this is where
Redux looks like basically just a global
object which is separated from our
application awesome now that's it for
scaffolding it so now let's create that
action for creating the to do
okay guys so we're gonna be starting
with the first two letters of crud um
create and read so let's back up and go
back to our form alright so on reform
our bunny we have a button here that's
just not doing anything let's add a
click event to it so when we click we're
gonna run ad to do all right
and yep and then we're going back to F
da component that T is when I come in
here it's due and this ad to do will be
dispatching okay so basically our Redux
works is you dispatch an object and it
will go through the reducer and it will
look for that actions name and then run
that action again off that switch name
and we have in the reducer so you'll be
able to see it a lot better through the
Redux tools the readout step tool time
so I'm just going to set it up okay so
to call it you need that we need a first
install import redux so it's going to
quickly import a couple things are going
to pour redox and the select which I'll
be using in a little bit to get certain
pieces of the state from the redox
object alright and we're also going to
import one where they might as well do
it now we're gonna put observable for
mark oh you already have it silly me
okay
oh let's import i to do in here because
we're probably gonna have to use it that
sort to do state we set off alright so
in our add to do we're going to basic so
that dispatch
okay and this match takes an object and
the object has a type and the type will
be they get to do so that's good to do
is well shoot over there just Pennsy
inject it let's do it now
oh we need to pass the initial state as
well sorry so the readings I have that
needs to be initialized with the initial
state so we're just gonna pass in in
this show high initial state so the
interface for initial state okay and
there we go awesome okay so now let's go
back into our add to Do's
so we're going to dispatch the get to do
but we didn't import the actions yet
yeah we're getting ahead of ourselves
sorry about that folks we're gonna copy
this over yeah copy this over all right
and again we don't have this to do
action that was to do alright so there
we go now we have our get to Do's but
again we're not getting to Do's here I
apologize folks are actually creating so
create to do awesome and we're gonna
pass in a payload and the payload base
is gonna be the object that we're gonna
be passing in and we're just going to
basic go tour to do form and if we're to
do form gets submitted and because we
had that disabled on it and I'll quickly
show that disabled to you guys one more
time that's disabled until it's valid so
again they're not the user is not gonna
be submitting the form till it's valid
so we're gonna come in here we're gonna
do form that value so it's gonna pass in
um this form object right here on a
model into our form okay there are
dispatches create the dues all right so
let's go ahead and let's create that
function in our reducer for that create
two dues so we're gonna go back into our
reducer alright then we're gonna do we
import if we did okay so we're gonna so
case t dot create two dues create two
dudes states
okay and it's complaining that I don't
have the method so are the functions
quickly function so state states gonna
follow I to do state and I'll show you
why we want do that in a second okay so
right here we're gonna need to add the T
assign operator so it's gonna quickly
copy and paste the import over alright
you just do this actually okay so there
we go we import T aside so T assign
basically gives us um typing on the
object dot assign method okay so as you
can see for a curried - duze methods
here we want to return what I was
talking about earlier is a pure function
an object that doesn't mutate the
original state so you do that by object
out of sign but the thing is there's no
like type structure on it so basically
you could do kind of whatever you want
in there and you could add properties
that don't exist in the to do state so
basically what T and sign will be doing
is making sure that we can only assign
these properties within our I to do
state to it alright so after we got that
we're going to set it up
actually that payload okay so the action
I paddled again is that payload I passed
in in the dispatch loading which is
false which we're not loading anything
just yet loading will be true because we
will be loading something and then error
as no all right and I'll get to all that
in a second all wrap everything together
okay so there we go so basically right
here is this is just an object data sigh
returning a new object a cool thing is
we don't need to include the whole
objects properties again because again
we could just get rid of loading and
then we just use this like this and I'll
work just fine because again you know
we're not mutating the original object
we're creating brand new okay so now
let's talk about middleware and how
we'll be using it within our application
so basically we'll be using middleware
to make those HTTP requests come to our
database which is the JSON server to get
data from it and so let's go ahead and
let's set up that epic middleware okay
so yeah I kind of just alluded to it
it's actually this pattern is called
epic middleware and this is how you do
it's in the angular framework it took me
forever to figure out how to do this oh
man now a lot of documentation out there
so hope this could definitely help
people struggle less than how much I
struggle trying to figure out how to do
this okay so we're going to do HTTP
epics all right
so within this we're going to import a
couple of things I'm just gonna copy and
paste the moment first let's get a lot
of service oh man come on
where's my key Bonnie it's there it is
okay perfect let's add load of the
service let's import a couple other
things
again it's to do and let's import some
of our a xjx operators okay awesome
and let's also import no I think it's
all for now
oh wait now one more thing that's
important I to do state okay perfect
there we go
okay so now that we have all that set up
let's change this name to choose HTTP
HTTP epochs all right on to the
constructor
oh the te HTTP service in alright so now
it's not the method so the first method
we'll be creating is create to do to do
okay so the action is um the is the
property admitted by the observable from
redux
let's play function all right so let's
return that filter so we're going to
filter that for a type and then we're
going to do tight equals T dot create to
do so we're going to be looking at all
our Redux actions and we're going to be
checking the type property and we're
going to see if it is equal to create
two dews and if it's equal to create two
dues we will then be we're gonna flatten
an exam this is an admitted object by an
observable so we're gonna check those
and turn those emitted properties into
observables themselves flatmap okay and
then we're gonna actually perform my
HDTV or bus right here on all those
things being admitted up so process the
MV API URL this was set up by the way
back back to vague if you were wondering
plus - duze which is that part we have
the DB JSON file and we're gonna piss in
our dated a payload okay awesome
did I over shoot the yeah I did I
overshot the parenthesis there sorry
about that guys all right so after we do
that we're gonna run through a map
result okay type equals T dot so once so
after this is the result of the function
I'm gonna leave this blank just for now
and I'll set up the error to run a catch
so this is the this is the HTTP request
coming back to us
okay okay so right here we basically are
making requests to our API for the to
use to create them we're posting to them
and now that we get the data back Oh
what's this complaining about okay so
once we get the response back we're
gonna run that through another redux
action so we're going to quickly create
the action so we're to create two more
actions and our actions on folder so
we're going to be creating a create
to-do success and we're also going to be
creating an error handler for when our
HTTP requests error out and that's gonna
be called to do error let me just copy
and paste that over okay so now that we
have both of those let's go back into
our HTTP epic middleware and then let's
set those functions up so we're gonna be
running tight T dot create to-do success
so after we get a bag and successful
we're gonna be passing this action
through them through read out so that
I'm gonna send the payload as so to JSON
all right awesome and then in here we're
gonna be running TWP - duze error there
it is perfect all right I'm gonna set
the payload as air three yards come on
there we go okay perfect okay so there's
our first um epic middleware a function
set up let's go ahead back into our to
do reducer alright so we're gonna have
that a couple more cases here let me
quickly add them so as you can see
there's a lot we need to just to get
this one API request set up so again as
I talked about in the beginning of the
video this is for more medium to large
scale applications but again you know I
kind of want sure you gotta do
this and I'll show you how to make it
easily scalable for your near the
large-scale applications so I'm going to
copy over the case the two cases that we
need which would be get to do success
and we're gonna also need excuse me it's
create to do success I apologize guys
I'm going to copy that with over - okay
and we're also going to do - duze error
alright so there's the two actions and
then we have to create those two
functions so let's come up here and
create those two functions so we're
gonna do create to do success there it
is alright so basically what we're doing
here is once we get all to do stay back
from the middleware that will intercept
the action coming through the pipeline
of redux and then run through each of
your requests and past the action up a
little bit we're gonna then became
captain eating onto our existing state
of two dudes again don't get us confused
that were actually manipulate excuse me
don't get this confused that we're
actually of manipulating the original
state we're creating a new state we're
just adding it on to all the original
states in another object
sorry about that getting confusing so
there is your creature to success
function and then we'll come down here
and also add a - duze error function
alright so this one's pretty simple if
there's an error we're just gonna attach
the pail of the arrow to the error right
there perfect awesome
so one last thing we need to do is we
need to register these on the App
component on the App module so remember
I talked about this array here at being
middleware well this is where you would
set it up so it's a real quickly alright
so we come in here
we do create middleware create epic
middleware this starts to dues ooh
item dependency inject it I'm sorry guys
let me go ahead and do that right now I
apologize
so let's come up here happy just do down
here so to dues HTTP epochs there we go
to do is a TV epic service perfect and
now we can do it so this have to do is
to dooms HTTP epic service would I oh
come on lower case there we go
dot create to do perfect alright we got
the we got it registered so now I'm
going to open up our network tab so we
can see the requests I'm also going to
open up our dev tools the cool
time-traveling alright so yeah it's just
a one-time wonder let's see let's see if
I got it so we're coming here with Ed
and Tom we're in Tom click Add and boom
ok so you can see it looks like we
didn't get an actual hf xhr request but
if we look over here we could see oh our
created news thing worked ok so it looks
like it worked let's check the state as
you can see the tom steak I added on
perfect so now let's go ahead and just
real quickly figure out what we did
wrong how to fix it twins hours later ok
guys sorry about that now let's fix what
was going on so first time to come in
here I'm going to add the provider so to
do epic service there we go add the
service as a provider and then we're
going down here in a dependency inject
it to do epics to do epic service
awesome and then we're gonna come in
here they're gonna register it right
here to do epics create to do perfect
there we go
alright so now we have the epic
middleware
I'm creating we're gonna fix something I
had wrong with the reducer earlier that
you don't need to touch this stay right
here so I want to get rid of it and then
let's put mega into our HTML because I
found something else
kind of embarrassing as you can see I
accidentally added an edgy submit
property to run add to new and this
click event trying to add to do so this
would actually relied twice i'm smears
with a quick click about right there on
the button alright so let's close it
down and if men you're gonna want to run
is JSON server - - watch DB JSON and go
ahead and run that command and you will
see that on locals three thousand or two
dudes will be available with restful api
all right so it's clear on console and
let's make our first request so i'm
gonna open up the read up step tools as
well as we could see we have our next
state up - duze which is again just the
initial state up that we defined earlier
so let's do Tom Jones click Add and as
you can see we have made a network
request a post request to the - duze API
they came back and we have this error
here create - duze the difference is
that loading is now true and then we go
to create a new success we can see
loading is now false and there is our
to-do right there awesome perfect
alright so there we go we have our
create tom enabled so now let's go ahead
and get those two do's and display on
the page
alright guys so actually let's get put
that up to do that we just created on
the screen so to do that I'm gonna come
in here I'm going to add an observable
varna create an observable we're gonna
be calling it public to do States
it's gonna be an observable oh type I to
do an array about to do okay awesome to
them once we have that we're gonna come
down here do this to do state equals
okay so we can subscribe to the store
the Redux store and we can get the state
after the action as you know manipulated
it so we give that action a minute to us
for that strength through subscribing to
the store okay but again if we look at
our initial state of the object which is
right here problem we don't really need
loading or error
well Justin just for this demo we're
only gonna really focus on two dues that
we only want to pass the two dudes down
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
basically use this coopera called select
and then we're just gonna only get the
to do is we're going to dudes dot two
dues because remember to dues is that
array within the two dues object okay so
now that we got that rid go back over to
our HTML okay so we comment this out I
don't want to waste all this time
creating all this so I'm gonna quickly
go over it for everyone so basically
what I'm doing is I'm using the if-else
intent which is new to angular 4 and I'm
most using the async pipe so basically
the async pipe will set up subscribe and
it'll also set up on subscribe to that
observable and whenever the observable
admit something out up it will then put
it as to dues so anytime that to do
state amid something up on the async
pipe will pipe it to the Tuesday
so this will be sure that none of this
content will load until something is
admitted of through that observable and
if nothing is emitted up we go through
the Alice which is loading and it's
gonna unload up show a loading with the
spinner okay awesome so now that we have
that let's get it on the page gonna come
in here and click and and boom there we
go there is our first to do on the page
now I didn't fully complete all the
functionality for yet so it's going in
let's fix the folks analogy for the
checkbox real quick because I'm pretty
sure yep if we see it's not gonna do
anything on it so as you see our
checkbox right here we're just gonna add
just some properties to it so I'll check
for us okay so maybe the name of Fleet
and then we're gonna do a true ID is
equal to I so I here so we're iterating
over all the two dues data because
remember that's what's emitted up from
the observable that we pipe the basing
pipe and we're gonna set the index of I
so we're gonna set the attribute ID to
the index and then I'm going to come
into the label and if you want a label
in the future this is how you would do
it I'm not gonna add one but I might as
well just put it in there in case so I'm
in the future wants to do it
I hear they use a table right here so
that'll match them up perfect
alright okay then there's one more thing
that we need to do is we need a second
check check property so to set the check
property we're just going to do extra
check we're gonna bind to it and then
we're gonna run to do complete so we're
gonna put this in a ternary PLDT but
this in a ternary operator so if two
technically is true where it's gonna
pass an empty string and then if not do
null and if it's no then this check
actually won't even be there so now that
we click here we need to create our to
do one more time because again we're not
getting the two dues
surely the only time to do is actually
going up there is when we create it so
that's why I only see one even though
our database probably as multiple to do
so there we go we have it created and
our check box is working so now let's go
to our DVD JSON I'll show you what I
mean
we have a whole bunch of news on our
to-do list in our database for only one
showing and that's because we're not
getting all the to dues we're just you
know posting the new one on there and
showing that one only so now let's
create the functionality to go and get
the to do so we're gonna go back into
our app that component that h that TS
and we're gonna ng it we're gonna create
a dispatch to get all our two news for
us
I'm just gonna quickly in G readouts
dispatch pass and type and the types
gonna be TD I get to dues okay so I've
got that in there
so now let's go into our that big
middleware so you see this is definitely
tedious I'm just gonna kind of copy and
paste this so doesn't take too long to
do and we're going to go copy and paste
over they get to do right here alright
so it gets to do success again yes we
have to go and create a get to do
success coming here export cons get to
dues success dues
okay now let's go into our middleware or
excuse me our middleware our reducer I
already go into our reducer then we're
gonna set it up there so let me just
quickly copy and paste this over oh we
actually need everything so here's the
success and we actually don't even have
to get so let me the cavea paste that
one over as well okay there we go so we
have both those they're awesome and now
let's create the two functions for them
again I'm going to copy and paste it
just say a little bit of time
so here is our get function right here
alright and we don't need action I feel
it right there and next up we're gonna
do get to do success all right awesome
so there we go so now last but not least
let's go to our app module and let's add
it to middleware create epic middleware
this to do epic stats get to do is there
we go alright so now let's open up Redux
and as you can see it already work well
just look to see what happened they get
the dues ran and then they get to your
success ran and then we have all our two
dues in here awesome so there's our two
dues perfect okay so next up we're going
to be going into updating
okay so now we want to update the
completed so remember we check the boxes
completed and we click refresh the state
will be persisted so let's go ahead and
do that so first up we're going to have
to navigate to the apt I've liked more
about HTML then we're going to go into
our check box then on the input we're
gonna add a click event and so I was
gonna run complete to do to do okay
there we go and let's go out after I
want that TS and then let's create that
function complete to do and then wrong
we have the to do right here
you read of stuff dispatch we're gonna
do tight is tea oh you know what I got
ahead of myself
scrap the Eddie action so let's go into
our actions let's add all of them you
know what I'm just gonna add all them
I'm gonna add the update and I'm going
to add the delete ones right now so we
could say some 10 so we're going to
these to act we actually had these four
actions all right we already have delete
to do that's good so let's hear it
complete to lead
sorry I just need an assist that's
actually so yeah that was earlier okay
awesome got all our actions in perfect
now let's go back to our app dr. Vaughn
OTS and let's do tight T dot complete to
do okay then we need to pass in the
payload of the to do sure let's see um
yeah we're passing to do so we're
passing the pram we had okay so now yes
let's do that whole process again it's
they're going to come here and I'm gonna
quickly copy and paste it okay
so there's complete to do is go to our
reducer and then let's add those two
functions complete to do a complete two
to success and you know what I'm gonna
add the delete as well because you know
what I'm not going to just go back to
the whole price let's do it all right
now so there's the complete to do
complete to do success then now let's
add delete to do delete to do success so
then I'll add the associated functions
for all them so there's four functions I
need to add let's go up here let's add
the four functions which are your the
first two which are complete to do I
then complete the new success and then
delete to do delete to success all right
awesome so we have those there so then
let's go back into our epic middleware
and then let's just add the function a
little bit ahead of time because we
don't want to navigate through the whole
process again and let's add the delete
to do epic middleware okay there we go
so one thing the note on this one we're
doing something a little bit different
the process on TV we have the ID in the
query string right here for both the put
and the delete request and also we're
not running a delete an action of delete
to do success some people might want to
return the object and use it but again
we don't need to use it we just want to
once we delete it we want to get the two
dudes again
so once there to do is talita we're
gonna get it ourselves so we're on they
get to dues action okay awesome so now
let's go into our middleware or excuse
me our app that module now let's
register both those and I'm just gonna
copy and paste those bad boys over
alright here we go
so there they both are oh you see I
called it differently so do that fix
okay got both of them over awesome so
now
let's go back into rehab da component TS
and then actually let's just add on the
delete functionality while we're at it
so on the trashcan I'm just going to
quickly set up a click event
solely to do to do all right then what's
going to our epic 20s and then since we
already have it set up this will be very
easy to choose this going to be delete
to do to do hi to do stop ng redux dot
dispatch basically it's gonna be the
same as as above but we're just gonna
have to change the type to delete okay
there we go
and awesome alright so we got that all
there let's put this over there and
let's check the functionality of the
whole thing I'm gonna open up so we can
see if our network requests are going
through correctly alright so let's just
create a whole bunch of them there's a
pair of a bunch of time times okay so
first thing you want to check is if we
check the first one you'll see
okay so complete to do right here ran
and it looks like everything worked out
so let's refresh the page and make sure
it work oh but first let's check our
HTTP request you have to put 200 refresh
the page looks how you didn't work
that's a bummer
let's see why
oh you know what I forgot to change it
oh uh I was passing the same object into
it I have to actually you know change it
before I pass into it so let's do that
real quick so we need to do equals to do
dot complete to do not complete equals
bang to do not complete equals bang to
do that complete there we go okay so now
we're actually changing it you don't any
see the network tags we know the request
is going through check the first one and
then let's refresh the page and is it
gonna be still
check yes it is awesome so our pull
request worked and just to show you will
check a couple others not print to
refresh there we go
this state is being persistent we took
out a DV dot JSON we will see that the
state has definitely been changed to
true for a complete for the first three
awesome all right so then last but not
least let's check out our delete
functionality so it should delete it and
then it should run the gif command to
get the new observable then new to run
the delete that it should run the get to
do is to get the new two dudes that are
still there on the JSON object and let's
just see if our to-do list matches up
with our JSON object and yes it does we
have to - duze in our DB JSON the two
dudes on the page alright so there it is
building it to use lists with angular
before and redux I hope you guys like
that hope you guys learn something oh I
really enjoyed making this video and
there's a lot more to come
you know now that I'm sin of them is
gonna be creamy these these uh excuse me
now that I'm said I'm just gonna be
cranking these videos out so be ready
and yes thanks for watching